winding its way through the rolling
hills of southern scotland the borders
railway is one of the country's most
spectacular routes but it's not just the
scenery that marched this house is
something special it is the best example
of a successful campaign to reinstate a
rail line axed half a century ago at
Edinburgh Waverley Station the border
service is always busy it's far exceeded
all expectations of passenger numbers
since reopening three years ago you
might expect three years after opening
that growth would start to tail off now
it's not on the Border's railway that
growth is actually accelerating which
means we're going to have to operate
longer trains on this route and I think
there's more growth to come as well it's
here 30 miles from Edinburgh and the
central borders with the real week
terminates if you want to go any further
south you need to take a car a bus or
some other form of transport but
crucially not the real way real
campaigners are now pressing the case
for extending the line beyond the
central borders and onto Carlisle
reconnecting struggling towns like hike
the closure of the railway in the 60s
marked a significant decline in hikes
fortunes with the loss of industry and a
fallen population and that's a huge new
viaduct here the old track bed is still
visible local campaigner Marian short
believes it's time politicians started
prioritizing the regeneration of the
rail network I think unless you live in
a rural area people don't actually
understand about the social isolation
and the fact that there is no
connectivity between city to city
across the UK many communities were
similarly traumatized by what became
known as the Beeching cuts 5,000 miles
of track was lost a third of the network
and more than 2,000 stations axed but
half a century on grassroots campaigns
to reinstate some services are enjoying
increasing success in recent years 500
miles of new track have been laid and
400 new stations opened including here
at Horak Parkway on the outskirts of
Bolton we've seen the railways in the
past being considered the 19th century's
technology and a legacy if you like but
what we're seeing now is a change in
that that it was really not being
regarded as a strategic part of the
emissions future infrastructure and
something which has to be invested in
back in the borders south of hike this
heritage railway runs on a kilometre of
track along the old Waverly line route
it's a glimpse into the past but these
enthusiasts believe reintroducing
passenger services here is easily
achievable
there's no engineering problem that they
couldn't get over there is some major
engineering work so would need to be
done and hopefully we couldn't make a
really good case for it and get it
straight across the border stunning
viaduct sand railway tunnels would all
need substantial work before passenger
services could run here again but
campaigners see just a fraction of the
funds earmarked for the troubled cross
rail or hs2 projects would help restore
rail links to some of the country's most
isolated communities mark white sky news
on the old Waverly line in the Scottish
Borders